[Music]
and out of my conversation with amanda
knox about justice in america high
profile cases making headlines black
lives matter
the police and her own exoneration and
the killing of her
overseas roommate since then she has
authored a book
and has begun hosting a podcast and
facebook show called the truth about
true crime
she's advocating for a renewed focus on
fairness for defendants
while acknowledging advocates on all
sides of hot button issues
could benefit from a time out for
self-reflection
amanda you as an american were
exonerated of a murder in italy are
there parallels to your case in the
american justice
system oh my gosh um
so many i i it's hard to count how many
um i think that the criminal justice
system throughout
the world um and particularly here in
the united states
is often thwarted by a number of
different
issues within the criminal justice
system i mean what we're looking at
is a system where prosecutors law
enforcement police investigators
are not incentivized to find the truth
they're incentivized
to win they're incentivized to find
answers and
and you know tie a neat little bow on
societal problems
and that means that there is inevitably
going to be people
who can't afford the kind of justice
that they deserve
and the kind of defense that they
deserve um becoming victims of the
criminal justice system here and abroad
when you talk about affording that sort
of defense they deserve are you talking
about lawyers fees we have public
defenders of course
or is it getting into forensics and
other things that cost a lot more money
absolutely i mean it comes to all of
those things right so
public defenders we know are not given
the resources and funding they need
to actually provide the service that
their clients deserve
um especially considering the kind of
resources that we make available to
prosecutors
um beyond that what is necessary
to these days to prove one's innocence
is
forensic testing is you know we need all
of these very expensive resources that
most people do not have
available to them it's a common problem
that if you can afford someone to do the
proper investigation
you have a chance of justice in our
criminal justice system
and the key word i think there was
proper investigation because courts have
to
authorize some degree of investigation
states
set aside money for defendants who don't
have the money to pay otherwise to
actually
pay for those services up front the
question is are they sufficient
right and also are the state entities
being incentivized
to pursue all of the available leads
that are available to them are they
following where the evidence is leading
them
or are they pursuing only evidence to
confirm a theory that they can then
present
to a court when long-time
daily returns amanda knocks on the hit
true crime series tiger king
and her stern warning for the audience
the conversation continues in just a
moment
[Music]
another move from my conversation with
murder exoneree amanda knox who has
turned her attention toward advocacy for
defendants finding themselves in the
same situation
she was once in knox identifies with
protesters against overzealous
prosecutors and police brutality but
believes it's unfair to characterize
police officers
as a whole as evil
the black lives matter movement and
protests across the country have changed
the conversation about the role of the
police
what's your assessment of the alleged
acts of the police
and the response from the communities as
you look at these protests big picture
it's so so important that these
conversations
are finally finally happening it's a
shame that it's taken this long
and i share the protesters sense of
urgency that these
issues need to be addressed now we need
to address the root causes
of crimes and we need to remember to be
cautious against any kind of us versus
them mentality
us versus them mentality is the root of
police brutality
because the police have otherized whole
communities
that they don't view as people that they
are
there to protect but to protect against
and we should resist any kind of
language that also
otherizes police officers that is not
taking into account their humanization
as well we need to look at the
incentives
and root causes of all these social
dysfunctions and address them directly
nox's opinions on current social issues
are influenced of course by her own case
she talked about what she says went
wrong in italy a decade ago
and about a few other high-profile
people claiming
their own innocence these days the
police
are not doing things because of
malicious intent
i don't think that that's what's
happening i think what the police are
doing
is they're following the path of least
resistance and they're finding the
person who is most vulnerable
to manipulation basically
um so they found me they saw me in a
vulnerable state
they saw that i had no one there to to
protect me to stand by me
my parents weren't there i was alone
and i was pushed to the point where i
broke basically i told the police again
and again and again
everything that i knew they didn't
accept
that i didn't know anything more than
what i was saying
and they pushed me to the point where i
began to believe
what they told me which was that i had
amnesia
and didn't remember all of the things
that i
knew about the crime it seems like a
far-fetched theory by the police
oh certainly well i mean i think that
when
i was going through my interrogation the
police didn't
know what happened okay they thought
that i knew what happened and they
thought
that there was some kind of sex game
that went awry because there had been
evidence that my
roommate had been assaulted sexually and
that somehow
i might know who might have done it that
i might have been involved
and if i a young woman with no criminal
record
were involved then it must be some kind
of
horrendous sex game that's the theory
and it all derived from trying to force
me into
a sexual assault murder equation
that i certainly did not fit into
prosecutors and law enforcement are
incentivized to win at all costs
to not admit fault and in order to do so
they basically railroad innocent people
speaking of innocence a lot of
high-profile people in true crime series
are professing theirs
so big question should joe exotic from
tiger king
be pardoned be pardoned
um let's see i mean so i don't want to
make any strong claims about any case
that i have not personally looked into
um i have not personally looked into the
joe exotic
case i saw a documentary like many of us
saw
and my simple reaction to that case
was actually in response to carol baskin
and
the number of people who saw a
documentary and made a claim
about how carol baskin killed her
husband and
i found that it was irresponsible for
anyone to be going around
claiming that someone killed their
husband because they happen to see a
documentary series that's not enough
to actually make any kinds of claims of
guilt or innocence
as to carol paskin specifically when she
says she had nothing to do with her
husband's disappearance do you believe
her
i think that there is enough
circumstantial evidence to pursue
an investigation but as far as what was
presented to
within the documentary i can't say
either way if i believe her or not
all journalists and all prosecutors and
you know are all going to be coming
presenting evidence to you from a
certain perspective
and their their ins their perspective is
informed by the information and the
research that they've done
but that doesn't mean that their
perspective should necessarily be yours
it's important to hear the other side
to weigh the evidence and to give it
if you want to make a claim or an
assertion
any kind of conviction needs to have
been the amount of context and homework
done that most people don't
want to do frankly your work generally
encourages people to reflect on criminal
cases by looking beyond headlines to not
rush to judgment it sounds like that's
basically what you're suggesting here
absolutely i mean
these are real people's lives and it's
easy to forget that when we see
someone's
face on the front page and their name in
a headline
these are human beings just like you and
me and they deserve
no matter what they've done every
benefit of the doubt and every
protection that our state has to offer
amanda knox thanks for the conversation
thank you
[Music]
you